Hi, everybody. Thank you for joining us.
Today, we're going to have a session on the
flip side of the benefit of immunotherapy for
cancer, which is the side effects from that
therapy. So these are the so-called
immune-related adverse events.
They can affect any organ system in the body, and
we have numerous examples at this point.
Literally, any tissue can become inflamed in someone who's receiving
immunotherapy for cancer. The most common tissues actually
fall into some general categories.
So barrier tissues like the skin, the gut,
and the lungs are very frequent targets of these immune-related
adverse events. And then endocrine organs, the
most common being the thyroid gland, but every endocrine organ has also been
described as a target.
The most common
severe
immune-related adverse event is colitis or inflammatory
toxicities in the gut. I mention that because that is going to be a
theme that runs through a lot of today's talks.
My talk will start. I'm going to do a little bit of an overview of what we
know about immune-related adverse events in the colon in
humans, and then the following two speakers are going to
talk about an area in this research that really is
extremely important and still really at the beginning, which is
mouse models of immune-related adverse events.
The field has really been held back by our
inability to study in detail the
mechanisms that are driving these toxicities.
And we have a lot of technologies to start to study this in humans, but when we
come up with hypotheses, it can be very hard to test them.
And many people have tried to study these toxicities
in mice. The two speakers today have, in my
opinion, really brought this field to the point where we
can actually start to learn something from our animal models.
So with that, we'll move on to
our first
talk.
Maybe.
Oh, sorry about that.
And I'm going to be talking about the differences
between CTLA-4 and PD-1 colitis.
These are my disclosures.
And can we start the timer?
Thank you. So
immune-related adverse events, as I mentioned, are a side effect of immunotherapy
for cancer, but they're more than just a side effect.
They're a model for understanding fundamental mechanisms of
immune regulation in humans. And what I mean by
that is that these toxicities, when
we
block PD-1 or CTLA-4, the
toxicities are the phenotype of receptor loss.
And so they give us a window into what those pathways were doing in
that patient in the moments before they had treatment.
I think this is important for understanding fundamental mechanism,
again, of immune regulation. It's also an opportunity to
understand the first steps in autoimmune disease.
And these inflammatory reactions are not the same as
autoimmune diseases, but they have many things in common, and we
have the ability to watch them unfold.
We know exactly what the immune perturbation is, we know exactly when it
occurred, and so we can study each step in
that process. And so I think of them as a human
model of the human diseases that we care about.
Again, not exactly the same thing as those diseases, but potential
insights into what the earliest stages of inflammatory disease looks like.
In addition to being, I think, fundamentally interesting from a
scientific perspective, they're also a really complicated clinical problem.
Why is that? Well, we're trying to minimize morbidity and mortality from
these toxicities at the same time that we're balancing the protective
effect of immunotherapy against the cancer.
And getting that balance right is really tricky, especially when you
don't know what the mechanisms are driving the toxicities.
We've learned a lot about the mechanisms that govern immunotherapy
response.
But it was with that goal in mind that got me studying
immune checkpoint inhibitor colitis or CPI colitis, as it's here.
And the experiment we did was to take three groups of
patients and take biopsies from their colon.
The populations that we studied are going to be color-coded in the next set of
slides. So in green, we have healthy controls, gray are a
different kind of control, people on immunotherapy who did not have
colitis, and then yellow are the patients who had
colitis from immunotherapy.
And we studied these biopsies by multi-spectral flow
cytometry and single-cell RNA sequencing.
And a few things I want to point out about this cohort of 24 patients.
First, almost all of them received dual checkpoint blockades, CTLA-4 and
PD-1 inhibition, but a couple of them did get
CTLA-4 blockade alone. These patients were biopsied within
days of onset of symptoms. One patient was actually biopsied on the day they
first had symptoms. Only one patient in the entire cohort had steroids
before the biopsy. So we're really looking at the earliest stages of what is
going on without any other immune manipulation.
You may be wondering, where did those gray patients come from?
So those are people who had symptoms suggestive of ICI
colitis, who ultimately didn't have it on biopsy.
And they fall into two groups. Half of them had inflammation in the upper GI tract
alone, and half of them had no inflammation anywhere in their GI
tract.And I'm not going to show you any of this data really today,
so I'm just going to say it, that if you look at the gray controls and the green
controls by many, many different measures, we were unable to find any
differences between those two populations.
So what did we find? Well, as you would expect, these are CD45
cells, unbiased clustering. We found all the
populations you would expect to find in immune cells in the colon.
And if we group those cells by where they came
from, you can see that there are two populations that really are
all yellow from patients with colitis. So what are those cells?
Those are cytotoxic cells, high levels of activation markers, making
interferon gamma and proliferating.
If we dive down into sub-clustering, look at the CD8 T cells alone, we see the
same thing. Cytotoxic effector cells, cycling T cells.
If we look at the CD4 T cells, we see again something that's very similar.
We see Th1 effector cells that are making interferon gamma and a smaller
population of cycling cells. We were
interested in figuring out what the origin of these
colitis-associated cells was. And the way that we decided to do this was to
take advantage of the fact that a T cell receptor is a molecular
barcode identifying clonally related T cells.
Every clonotype of T cell has the same T cell receptor.
It's genetically encoded, and so we can determine
relationships between T cells even if they have different
phenotypes.
And so this is a little bit of a difficult plot to look at,
so I'm going to walk you through it.
If we just focus on the controls over here because it's easiest, what we have on
the X and Y axis is each of the eight populations that we found
in the CD8 compartment. And if you take
this box here that says 86, that's 86
clonotypes of T cell that are overlapping
between column one and column two.
So what are those? Resident memory cells in the
interepithelial space and resident memory cells in the lamina propria.
So this is telling us that clonotypes found in those
two phenotypic compartments are actually related to each
other. Makes sense. In a healthy person, T cells can go back and
forth between the lamina propria and the interepithelial space.
We see the same thing in the no colitis patients as exposed to immunotherapy.
One of the many pieces of data that those populations are really the same and
something very different in colitis.
So we should focus first on the red because that's the easiest to understand.
Red is the two different colitis associated populations, the
cytotoxic cells and the proliferating cells.
And it's saying there's a tremendous amount of overlap between those two
populations. Again, it makes sense.
The cells that are activated and cytotoxic are the very
same cells that are proliferating.
What we did not expect to find was what we see here in yellow.
So those are clonotypes that are shared between
the resident memory cells and the colitis
associated cells, implying that the resident memory
pool is actually responsible for contributing all of
those colitis associated cells, or the cause of
colitis is activation of resident memory cells.
So I'm not showing you all the data that led up to this drawing, but the model that
we have is that at baseline, we have many resident
memory T cells in the colon. In fact, in many organs, particularly the barrier
organs.
When patients get immunotherapy, some of them have
reactivation of that resident memory pool.
Those cells start producing granzyme. They produce interferon gamma.
The interferon gamma acts on the tissue, but it also acts on macrophages.
Data I'm not showing you. Those macrophages become activated.
They secrete inflammatory cytokines and also chemokines,
which call in additional immune cells from the blood,
probably perpetuating the colitis.
And then something's going on with those regulatory T cells.
And we had a little bit of data from this initial experiment, but that was one of
our open questions. What's happening to the regulatory T cells?
So
we had an idea that there may be some loss of regulatory T cells,
and so our question was, are they actually depleted
by the CTLA-4 antibodies? Why did we wonder that?
Well, there are actually a number of publications that have shown this in mice, and
I'm showing you the first one here.
And what has been found is that mice who
are treated with CTLA-4 blocking antibodies actually have rapid
depletion of their regulatory T cells from their tumors.
This is one piece of data in the paper. This is a B16 melanoma model.
The mice have been given CD4 T cells that are specific for the
tumor, and you can see that in untreated animals, many of those CD4 T
cells differentiate into Tregs. If you give CTLA-4
antibodies, that Treg population vanishes.
And again, they're able to show that this is through
loss of the regulatory T cells. This is one
of their most compelling pieces of data.
Here, they've looked at the effect of immunotherapy
when the Fc gamma RII receptors were removed from the
mouse's genome. And what they find is that the therapeutic benefit of
immunotherapy vanishes. So their conclusion from this is that
you need to be able to deplete regulatory T cells for
CTLA-4 antibodies to be effective in mice.
Again, multiple other groups have shown this at this point.
So we wondered if that was happening in our patients.
And those are the Tregs. And you can see just from coloring, there are many Tregs
in the colitis patients.
If you look at total counts by flow cytometry, you actually see more regulatory T
cells. They have the same percentage CTLA-4 positive, and
they also have the same amount of CTLA-4 on their surface.
And I'll just remind you, these are samples taken very early on in the
colitis course.Suggesting that we're not really looking
too late. This is probably something still very early on in the process.
It's certainly possible, though, that we missed something happening in a regulatory
T cell subset.
So we put some thought into how could we actually probe this
question and we would expect if CTLA-4
antibodies are depleting regulatory T cells, the mechanism is
antibody binding to Treg, and then either NK cells or macrophages are
killing those Tregs. That should require the
CTLA-4 antibody. And so if we compare CTLA-4
colitis to PD-1 colitis, we may be able to see a difference
that will suggest that the CTLA-4 antibodies are depleting.
We didn't have enough data to do that in the initial experiment, so that's where
Lily Orgler came in. She's a post-doc in my lab.
And what Lily did was to take two published data sets, our
initial one, one that we contributed to a few years later, and then added
a bunch of additional PD-1 colitis cells to that
analysis. So we ended up with 230,000 cells where we
could actually do this comparison.
And this is the initial UMAP from that
combination analysis. Lily found, again, the same populations of cells
we were expecting to find. And at this high level, we found a
few general things. We found slightly
more CD8 T cells. Those are the dark blue lines in the
colitis patients. It is statistically significant, but it is a very
small overall effect on CD8 T cells.
And then there's a slight increase in the number of cycling cells that
we see. That's what we see in this dark red, and you can see there are a
few more of those bars. So high level,
small changes.
If we compare CTLA-4 and PD-1 colitis, we see no difference
again, at this high level.
So we then went and looked at CD4 T cells
in more detail by sub-clustering.
We identified 12 distinct populations of CD4 T cells.
And if you look here, you might not be able to read the labels, but you can see the
colors. Colitis has a lot more red, and obviously we colored
that on purpose. So the light pink are the
cytotoxic TH1, TH17 cells,
the dark pink are the Tregs, and then
the dark red at the bottom are the cycling cells.
And again, you can see it really looks like there are a lot more of all three of
those populations in colitis, and indeed, we do see that statistically.
In truth, we see statistical differences across all of these populations.
Most of them,
to me, do not seem like they're very meaningful.
The big differences really are in those populations that I highlighted.
And again, when we compare dual colitis CTLA-4 PD-1
blockade versus PD-1 colitis, we find no statistically significant differences,
including in the regulatory T cells.
We also looked at clonotypic expansion, and this was a big surprise to
us. Across all of these different groups, there's no significant
difference in the number of expanded clonotypes.
There are just as many expanded clonotypes in a healthy
person as there are in someone with colitis.
So this is what that looks like if you just place it on a UMAP.
All of the blue are expanded clonotypes, and you can see they
represent many of the populations that we were able to
identify. These are expanded resident cells.
These are the activated effector cells.
These are the proliferating cells.
But if you compare colitis to the healthy controls, you do see a difference
in which cells are expanded. So the expanded cells are largely the
resident memory cells in healthy patients.
In the colitis patients, it's really those effector cells and those
proliferating cells.
And we can look at this across each one of the groups.
And so here, everything is down-sampled, so they're comparable to each other.
And again, you can see in the two control groups, it's really in that resident
memory population that you see expansion.
In the colitis, it's really in these activated cells.
And there's a lot more expansion in the CTLA-4 population than in
the PD-1.
If we look at this another way where you're looking at what cells are expanding,
again, you can see the pink bars are really where most of the
clonotypic expansion is occurring in CTLA-4 blockade
colitis.
Next question we had is are there specific Treg
phenotypes in these samples? So
we went in and we sub-clustered the regulatory
T cells. And if you sub-cluster the regulatory T cells, we found 11 distinct
populations. So there are different kinds of regulatory T
cells here.
And again, we find some that really do seem to be
a little bit more preferentially expanded in the
colitis patients.
And in particular, we see these
S1P1R positive regulatory T cells
that seem to be quite expanded, as well as the cycling cells.
It's not really the best way to look at these data, though.
And the reason for that, at least in my opinion, is that we know the
overall Tregs are expanded. So this is just looking at percentage
of Tregs. I think a better way to look at this is percentage of
CD4 positive cells. That gives you a good sense
of what's actually happening, which is that over
all of these populations, you're actually seeing some measure of expansion.
There are more regulatory T cells compared to what you see in the
healthy controls. There are some populations that are relatively
expanding.
This is showing that in a quantitative way, and you can see
across the board, every Treg population that we identified
is either increased in colitis or the same in colitis.
And some of them are quite a bit more expanded.
So then we finally get to that question that we had at the beginning.
Do we see any difference in which
populations expand if you compare CTLA-4
blockade to PD-1 colitis?And the answer is
sort of. So I'm only showing you the populations that
differ. Almost everything that we look at is exactly the same between
CTLA-4 colitis and PD-1 colitis. The differences are two
populations. One are these naive Tregs, so no
elevated activation markers. And what you can see there is
that the CTLA-4 dual colitis has
the same number of these naive cells as the two control populations.
PD-1 colitis has an expansion of those.
I honestly, at this point, don't know what to make of that.
These are sort of hot-off-the-press kinds of data.
The other population that changes are the
S1PR1 positive
regulatory T cells, cells that we think are migrating out of lymph
nodes into the colon. And there we see a big
expansion in CTLA-4 colitis that's really not present in
PD-1 colitis, so a distinct phenotypic difference.
What we didn't find were any populations that seem to be
depleted in CTLA-4 colitis relative
to PD-1 colitis or relative to the controls in this analysis.
Again, these are
biopsies that were taken from patients very
soon after the onset of symptoms and only one patient
in the entire cohort had steroids before the biopsies were taken.
So this isn't sort of clouded by steroids or other kinds
of colitis-associated treatments.
Little bit more about this S1PR1 positive population,
which again, we're still
trying to study in more depth. These are also the cells that
show the most clonotypic expansion.
So that implies that there's something important about these cells.
These cells are in some way responding to the colitis that's
occurring.
Whether they're having any beneficial effect in controlling the colitis is an open
question, but they're clearly where the clonal expansion is occurring most.
So that brings me to the conclusion for today.
Points that I want to emphasize, both CTLA-4 and
PD-1 colitis are characterized by an expansion of resident memory
CD8 T cells. They really are the same in that category.
Tregs are broadly expanded in CTLA-4 and PD-1 colitis.
CTLA-4 antibodies do not deplete these Tregs
from what we can tell in human colitis.
CTLA-4 inhibitor colitis is characterized by an
expansion of these TH1/TH17 effector cells.
I'll tell you, we cannot separate those two phenotypes from each
other, so the TH1 and TH17 are
stuck clustered together. And then we also see this expansion of the
S1PR1 positive Tregs.
And with that, I would like to thank the many people who have been involved in
this, and particularly Lily, who I emphasized before, and I am
happy to take any questions.
And just because this is recorded, if people could ask questions at the microphone.
Thank you. My name is Patrick from BMS. Great presentation.
So I think my question
is trying to understand the balance between the expansion of
Tregs and that inflammatory phenotype, which is colitis.
And perhaps the more interesting question is,
do you think that these S1PR positive Tregs have
some sort of inflammatory phenotype that together with the
TH17 just amplifies stuff? Because I would think that if there is an
expansion in the Treg population, in a sense, it should counterbalance
their pro-inflammatory TH17.
Yeah. So I think I'm following this question, but
what I think is happening is that we're getting expansion of Tregs that
are trying to compensate for the
inflammation but are insufficient.
In the CTLA-4 colitis, CTLA-4 is blocked, and
so one of their major mechanisms of control of
inflammation is actually blocked, and so I think that that is
part of what's happening there. PD-1 colitis overall
is less likely to be a sort of out-of-control, rapidly worsening
colitis, and so it's possible that in that
form of colitis, part of the reason why it's not as out of control as CTLA-4
colitis is that those Tregs are having more of a benefit.
And if we were to block CTLA-4 in that moment
in them, we would actually get something that's that much worse.
Okay. Thanks.
Very interesting findings.
Based on the memory cells that are being activated, it's
suggestive that maybe these patients are
right on the cusp of maybe having colitis, but they're being held in check by the
Tregs, and the treatment has then released them.
And if you think that's the case, could this be perhaps
developed as a preclinical diagnostic to maybe exclude some
patients that would be at risk for having this?
So I think it's a really interesting question.
I think the answer is there's something different about the people who
get this colitis,
and I think it's immunologic. We don't know what it is yet.
I'll say that if you get dual checkpoint blockade, you have about a
40% chance of developing colitis at some point in your treatment course.
It's not necessarily going to be the very severe kind, that's sort of 15% to
20%, but a lot of people can get this.
Could a lot of people be right on that cusp of inflammation?
I think yeah, right? I mean, we all have a diverse
microbiome. We constantly are having insults in our gut
that could be causing inflammation, and we're not getting
inflamed. And that may be because these systems work very well, and these are
the core regulatory pathways that do that, and we block them
andThe insult leads to inflammation.
Could we identify those people ahead of time? I think probably.
I think we really have to put more effort into studying people before they start
immunotherapy. And that is a tall order, but I think that's
where the human side of this needs to go.
I think in the mouse models,
to the extent that we could identify things ahead of time in mice and do something
hypothesis-driven, it would work better in people.
Yeah. Thank you.
All right. I think we should move on.
So our next speaker is Dr. Kristen Pauken from MD
Anderson,
and
I'm delighted to hear her talk.
You're a lot taller than me.
Sorry about that.
It's okay. The slides are taking their time.
All right.
So thank you, Michael, for that introduction and a huge thank you for the
invitation to speak at this meeting.
I'm really excited about being part of this session, talking about immune-related
adverse events and the sorts of things that we need to be
thinking about here. And so today, I'm really probably going to talk
about more problems than solutions.
But really, I want to bring light to what I think is this critical issue, and
that's whether or not migratory populations of immune cells or
resident populations of immune cells are really driving checkpoint
inhibitor-induced immune-related adverse events, or IRAEs.
I really have nothing to disclose.
So when we think about the pressing clinical problem that is IRAEs,
there are really three main issues.
First is risk prediction. We know that not all people who
receive immunotherapy for their cancer are going to develop IRAEs,
and so trying to understand the factors that contribute to having higher risk or
lower risk is not trivial. In terms of diagnosis,
we're often relying on patients to be able to identify that they're having
something wrong, and of course, these can happen anywhere in the body, so there's a
lot of symptoms that they have to keep track of.
And then often, we're waiting for referrals to specialists to
follow up and manage. And then with treatment, this is where things get really
tricky because we have to be able to get the toxicity
under control without completely derailing the anti-cancer response.
Because sometimes, we'll get dire to a point where it's like we have to
continue the immunotherapy or the cancer will take the patient, but we also have to
get the toxicity under control or the toxicity will take the patient.
And so often, these are being treated with immunosuppression, which hurts the
anti-tumor response.
So in terms of thinking about the critical research bottlenecks, we think that
research could really advance what we're doing in terms of risk prediction,
diagnosis, and treatment, but there's a lot of things that are holding us back.
The first is variable penetrance of IRAEs.
So as I mentioned, not everybody develops them.
And then there's variable presentation.
And so this has really, I think, been a testament to the complexity of the human
immune system. These can happen literally anywhere in the body.
They can happen early after we start treating. They can happen years later.
They can be mild. They can be life-threatening or even fatal.
They've been really all over the place clinically.
One of the most significant research bottlenecks is actually the inability to
meaningfully sample tissues prior to onset.
So with cancer immunotherapy, for example, we can very easily take a
biopsy of the tumor before we start.
We can call that time zero for our immunotherapy, and we can then sample at
various times after immunotherapy initiation.
But with the toxicities, because we don't know when they're going to happen or
where they're going to happen, getting that pretreatment inflamed tissue sample is
hard, because even within a single tissue, you can have areas
where the toxicity is prevalent and not.
And so knowing that you're sampling the right place is difficult.
Right now, disjointed efforts between studying the relationship of the anti-tumor
response and the toxicity response are challenging.
So these are happening in the same patient, but whether they have anything to
do with each other is unclear. And then, of course, when we treat a patient,
the cancer can respond to the treatment similar
to the toxicity. And so balancing that
dynamic is hard. And then I'm going to argue today that we really need to be
putting the effort into developing mouse models, because I think that the lack of
mouse models to recapitulate the key drivers of pathogenesis in patients is
really holding us back.
So what I want to focus on today is this importance of timing and
location and how we need to understand those two things to be able to better
monitor as well as better treat.
So obviously, we're talking about IRAEs for cancer patients, right?
And so when we first think about the anti-cancer response, many of us really
focus on the tissue microenvironment, the tumor microenvironment itself.
And for good reason. CD8 T cells do the majority of the heavy lifting in terms
of directly killing cancer cells with immunotherapy, and those cells
act in a contact-dependent manner.
So they have to be in the tumor to kill tumor cells.
Similarly, if it's T cells driving your toxicities, those cells have to be
in the inflamed tissue to be causing damage.
This is a little different from B cells, where secretion of their antibodies can
act at a long distance, but for T cells, being in the tissue is
important.
But as you can imagine where I'm going with this based on the picture that I've
shown, this is some Immunology 101.
This is really only the tip of the iceberg. The very tip, right?
These tissues is not where T cell responses start.
These tissues are where T cell responses end.
And so when we think about where T cell responses start, before activation,
naive T cells as well as B cells are completely anatomically
sequestered in spleen, lymph nodes, and blood away from these effector sites.
And they have to first become activated and then migrate to the tissue to
actually do any work.
Similarly, in terms of the innate immune system, there are some cells that seed
tissues early during life, and those are not necessarily constantly replenished.
But for most cells of the immune system, these are constantly being produced in the
bone marrow and exported into blood and then have to get called from blood into
tissue.So when we think about our
patients
defining immunological time zero is extremely
difficult. So in our mice, we know what time zero is.
We have an SPF mouse. We know when we give it a cancer.
We know when we do some sort of immunological perturbation to it.
But in people, we all have this rich and diverse antigen stimulation
history, and we're all our own unique walking case study.
And so with people, we don't know when they come in to receive checkpoint
inhibitors, whether or not they already have these populations in their tissues
because of some antigen stimulation event or if they're new because
we've started giving immunotherapy or both.
And understanding the answer to this question is extremely
important because it impacts how
we monitor, when, where, and how we monitor, also in terms
of how we treat.
So using colitis as an example here, starting with model one, that
tissue-resident leukocytes are driving pathogenesis.
As you can imagine, if your patients come in and they already have these resident
cells in their tissue, then you're going to want to direct your monitoring to
that tissue through biopsy. You're also going to be wanting to focus your
treatments to that tissue. So just to give some definitions, when I talk about
tissue resident T cells, I talk about T cells that had to first become
activated, and then they have to go to that tissue, and then they don't leave that
tissue. They're often associated with markers that are involved in their retention,
things like CD69 and CD103. We love them in cancer and infection
because they seem to work really well in terms of protective capacity.
But obviously in adverse events, this is an issue because if they're highly
functional and stuck there, they're a problem.
I will note the difference between tissue-resident and tissue-resident memory.
Memory means antigen's gone away.
So if antigen hasn't gone away, we typically don't give them the memory
designation.
So Donna Farber's lab has really come a long way in the context of infection in
defining these core transcriptional signatures, which can be really useful for
trying to identify these cells. As you can see here, there's a number
of markers associated with retention and then a lack of markers
associated with exit.
So certainly, if you take a biopsy of inflamed tissue in immune-related
adverse events, we can see signs that there may be resident
populations. So this has been seen in colitis, which
Dr. Dugan recently described. You can also see this in cutaneous
toxicities, myocarditis, neurotoxicities.
Certainly, once you take that sample, you can see those signatures.
The issue, though, is that just because at the time of toxicity you see
those signatures doesn't mean that those cells were necessarily there when you
started. And this is somewhere where I think mouse models are really important
because we can actually kind of suss that out.
We can ask, okay, if you have resident memory cells or you don't, how does that
change things? So why mouse models are important here actually stems from
work from Dave Masopust, who's a leader in this space, and they use this in the
context of acute viral infection to ask about residence.
So they used an approach which we cannot translate to patients, as you'd imagine,
where you surgically conjoin two animals together, and then over one to
two weeks, they will exchange a vasculature between them.
And if the cells are capable of leaving the tissue, you'll find them in the other
animal, and if they can't, then you won't.
And what they found was that in this acute viral infection, the overwhelming
majority of cells in the overwhelming majority of tissues were resident.
What was interesting and why it raises a sign of caution for what we're
doing in humans, when you look at those cells in different tissues, like the
pancreas, the salivary gland, or the female reproductive tract, there's extremely
variable CD69. And importantly, if you look at CD69,
that retention marker, the positive versus negative cells, the
CD69 negative cells in this setting were resident just like the CD69
positive cells. Similarly, CD103 has this same issue.
It tends to be a better marker for residents in epithelial layers and
less effective in lamina propria.
Adding another wrinkle to interpreting our single-cell RNA-seq data sets,
work from, again, the Masopust lab as well as John Wherry's lab and Laura McKay's
lab, have shown that exhausted cells can actually have a lot of transcriptional
overlap with bona fide tissue-resident memory cells.
And it seems like a lot of the same transcriptional machinery that helps resident
memory cells stay in tissues also helps exhausted cells stay in
tissues. And so this kind of complicates the picture
here. So when we think about tissue-resident populations, we
know that when we take biopsies of inflamed lesional tissues from these
patients, we see these resident-like cells.
Whether or not those are actually there when we start treatment, we don't know, and
that lack of the ability to do the pre-treatment
assessment is really challenging for
us.
So that brings me to the other half of the coin, and these don't necessarily have
to be mutually exclusive in a person, right?
These can both be happening at the same time.
We just need to understand the contribution of each.
So the other side of things is migration, and again, using the colitis
example because the colon is a place that has unique trafficking
receptors to get cells in, which is really, really, really helpful here.
So you can imagine if migration is critical for inducing colitis, then
blocking migration would help. And fortunately, there's inhibitors of the
integrin alpha 4 beta 7, which are clinically approved and regularly used in
colitis and have had a lot of success there.
So if you can block that migration and you have success, that's great.
But if the cells are already in the tissue, then blocking migration is not going to
be helpful.
So I want to really talk about how we measure migration and why it's important that
we develop animal studies to do this.
So this has been a major research bottleneck both in people as well as in mice, and
the reason for that, I've mentioned that cells have to go from the blood into
tissues. We know that they have intrinsic differences in their entry rates across
different leukocyte subsets. But as soon as it passes from the blood into tissue,
we have no idea how long it's been there, whether it's been a minute, an hour,
a week, a month. And for both cells of the adaptive immune system and the innate
immune system, we think that the time in the tissue really shapes their
phenotype and function. We know cells adapt in tissues.
And in the context of chronic antigen, this can really shape the functional output
of these cells.So as I mentioned before, in the context of residence,
parabiosis has been helpful here for asking if cells are capable of leaving
but because it takes so long for these blood vessels to form, it's not as useful
for studying acute migration events
Photoactivatable dyes are useful.
These are encoded in the germline, and you can shine light on external tissues, and
those cells will change colors. And while that's great, this has been
limited for the toxicity field because it requires extensive breeding.
Often, our mouse models are not on this background.
It's also really best for labeling external tissues, so it limits where we can use
it.
So fortunately for me, this is something that my long-term collaborator, Jason
Schinkel, was trying to solve for his own work, and he developed a timestamping
approach that I really want to highlight to allow us to actually track migration
from the blood into tissues. He has published a couple of papers on this at
this point if you're interested in checking out the method.
This is an adaptation over a technique that's been used for over 20 years in the
field. Again, Dave Masopust's lab has published a protocols paper on this.
Basically, you inject a fluorescently labeled antibody into the
vasculature three to five minutes before euthanizing the mouse, and you can see if
the cell's binding the antibody, they're actually in the blood and not the tissue
parenchyma. But if they're in the parenchyma, then they're IV-negative.
So we were interested in whether or not we could leverage this concept to track
migration into tissues since leukocytes have to traffic from the
blood into the tissue. And we knew that to do this, we needed
antibodies that would not cause deletion of the cells, would not themselves get
internalized and degraded, and would not leak into tissues.
And so we tested a whole panel of antibodies, giving CTV or
CFSE-labeled cells, so we could identify the cells independently of the antibody
and then harvested mice 10 minutes later.
And what we found was that certain antibodies that are known to really effectively
deplete cells do. Thy1.1 killed all the cells in 10 minutes.
CD8 and CD4 are well on their way. But CD45.2 and
CD45 did not. So it's like, great, you've gone from 3 minutes to 10 minutes.
How impressive is that, right? Well, we first looked at
CD45.2 and tried to elongate this.
And so what we found was that at 10 minutes, 24 hours, and 72 hours, we could
still very easily distinguish these cells from a no-injection control.
Kind of a word of caution here. When we compared CD45.2 to
the pan-CD45 epitope 30F11, you
can see that with the 104 clone, you get very little loss of
signal in that 10 minutes to 24 hours period, whereas with the
CD45 30F11 clone, we lose a lot of that signal in
the 24 hour period. And if we try to actually count the cells that we get
back, we actually lose a lot of the cells as well.
So if you're going to use this for your own work,
we certainly recommend the clone 104.
What I'm not showing is that at the concentrations that we're giving into an intact
CD45.2 mouse, we don't see any evidence of leakage into tissues.
This is also not saturating, so you can actually use the same clone over and over
again in different colors to create these temporal maps of how immune cells are
trafficking into tissues.
So my lab has been using this in the context of checkpoint immunotherapy to study
both the protective anti-cancer side as well as the pathogenic adverse
event side. These are the people who have been leading those projects.
And what we can do, if you have a CD45.2 expressing preclinical
model, you just do your normal experimental setup, and then you can start
injecting these antibodies. Like I said, within 72 hours of harvest,
we always include a three-minute control to exclude what's actively in the
vasculature.
So this is what a tumor looks like. We're at AACR. This is a cancer conference.
We always see in every tumor type that we look at, there's always a population of
cells actively in the blood. We kick those out.
We see a large population that is IV-negative.
Those are presumably the cells that have been in the tumor for longer than 24
hours. And then we have these 24-hour positive, three-minute negative that were
in the blood at that snapshot in time at 24 hours.
The label is actually a short labeling window and now is in the tumor.
So in terms of some controls, an uninjected control obviously is the ideal control.
But some other natural positives and negatives, the tumor-draining lymph node
always has very few three-minute positive cells, and the peripheral blood always
has a lot of three-minute positive cells.
This is what this looks like in other types of tissues.
So as I mentioned, my lab is using this in pathogenic immune responses.
This is the pancreas in an autoimmune prone NOD
mouse, and then cardiac tissue in a myocarditis-prone mouse.
We also have kidney and salivary gland shown from a mouse
that just has an MC38 tumor. No, it has a melanoma tumor. Excuse me.
And that is at homeostasis. You can see each of these different tissues has a
different three-minute versus 24-hour IV antibody profile.
What's cool is that when you perturb the immune system, the immune system responds.
And a lot of that response involves migration.
And so you can see this is the salivary gland in a mouse that got a
cancer vaccine. Suddenly, the 24-hour IV positive by three-minute
IV positive distribution changes.
So one of my postdocs in the lab, Ariel Desens, has been looking at this in the
context of the NOD
mouse model of autoimmune diabetes. Excuse me.
This is a mouse model that we know if we give PD-1 inhibitors, we get accelerated
diabetes onset, similar to what is seen in a subset of patients who develop
checkpoint inhibitor-induced
autoimmune-induced type 1
diabetes. And what we do is we just use our traditional
NOD CD45.2 mouse. We give anti-PD-1 to accelerate disease, and then we can give the
IV antibody.
So importantly, when we do this, this is at a time point where the field largely
believes that most of the heavy lifting in terms of diabetes onset is actually
happening directly in the tissue and is not being driven by migration.
But what you can see looking at these images, the IV antibody is in red.
We actually do get a lot of cells migrating into the tissue in this
acute inflammatory event. And I think it's really important to consider that both
residence and migration can be contributing to the disease at the same time.
Just because the cells already in the pancreas are going nuts doesn't mean that the
cells that are migrating in aren't also contributing to the damage.
We've started following up on this by flow.
This has been a model where we've seen a lot of variability, so we're still working
on statistical significance, but we think that this is promising.So how
do we extend this concept to patients?
Well, I think conceptually we could always extrapolate some of these
CD8 PET approaches, for example, to actually be able to track entry into
tissues. But while we continue to work on methods where we can actually
track recruitment in patients using therapeutic
antibody labeling, for example. I want to just take a moment to highlight
the peripheral blood and methods that we can actually use today to address
this question. So the blood, because it serves as this
critical window for migratory populations, both on the innate side as well as the
adaptive side, can be really, really useful.
The advantages of blood is that it's easy to longitudinally sample, it's not
invasive, and importantly, you don't actually need to know where the IRAE
will pop up. All you need to know is that
the blood is going to connect to everything.
In terms of the disadvantages of blood, there's tremendously high noise level.
Leukocytes do adapt once they go into tissues, and so you may not have the same
phenotypes in the blood that you would expect to see in the tissue.
And then deciphering between the adverse event and the cancer response is going to
be challenging here.
So in terms of one solution to this problem, we've been using single-cell
sequencing of the TCR as a barcode, which Dr.
Dugan alluded to, to enrich this signal from noise.
And what's so cool about this is that it's actually variations in the DNA sequence
of the TCR that dictate which antigens T cells can bind.
And when you sequence that barcode and T cells have the same TCR,
then they theoretically bind the same antigen.
And so as cells divide, you can track clonally related cells across time and space.
This is a method that I contributed to when I was a postdoc.
It was a project that was led by Mirami Singer, collaboratively with Arlene Sharpe
at Dildeout and Michael Rosenbloom.
And we started in tumors, where we were able to take tumor and paired blood from
both mice and people, perform 10x 5prime single-cell RNA-seq and
TCR-seq, and then we simply took our list of TCRs from the
tumor and asked if we could find those cells in blood.
So this is what it looked like in the context of tumor.
In color are the cells that we care about because they have matching TCRs to
tumor. And in blood, and in gray is the noise.
And so we can just kick out the noise.
We also showed in Arlene's lab as proof of concept that this can be done in
autoimmunity. This was a study led by Jenna Collier as a graduate student.
So this is in checkpoint-induced as well as spontaneous
NOD mice.
In Chloe Villani's lab at MGH, recently adapted this technique
in a really cool way to study the relationship between IRAEs and the tumor
response, taking heart tumor tissue and adjacent tissue.
And what she found in this study was, at least in the heart, the TCRs that were
found in the heart were mostly not overlapping with the tumor.
But I think that applying this to every IRAE and cancer type is going to be useful.
So like I've said today, we have a whole lot of problems.
I think a lack of a preclinical mouse models is a huge problem here.
And to propose a framework for how to address this problem.
This is a framework that we proposed in a review last year with Pam
Sharma as the lead author. This was originally for developing rational combination
therapies, but I think it also applies to IRAEs.
Really trying to learn as much as we can from patients using these small
tissue-rich clinical trials, feeding that data into computational algorithms like
AI and machine learning, but also developing better mouse models to recapitulate
what we see in humans.
So with that, I'd like to thank you all for your time and attention.
And again, a huge thank you to the session chair, Michael Dugan, for the invitation
to speak.
We do have time for some questions.
Hi, Kristen. That was really lovely.
I really like the CD45 labeling to
track cells that have recently or not so recently
migrated.
My question is, what are your thoughts about the emerging data that tissue-resident
cells can actually leave and then go back into a tissue?
And so if they're traveling from tissue to blood to tissue again,
how does this complicate their detection and trying to think about
using trafficking inhibitors to affect this population?
Yeah, it's a really interesting question.
So, to me, if a cell is capable of
leaving and then going back in, I wouldn't
by definition call it resident. The issue is that it's going to be
expressing all of those residence markers, right?
And so if you're taking a biopsy and you're asking, do I have resident cells?
Are those cells causing the problem?
But your resident cell population is actually contaminated with a whole bunch of
cells that are not actually resident and can go back and forth.
Then it makes, I think, interpreting those signatures that much more
challenging. From a trafficking
perspective, I think,
really it depends on what our ultimate goal is.
And I think the goals often are different on the cancer side than they are on the
toxicity side. On the cancer side, we're trying to get cells to go there and
then, as far as we know, stay there.
If they leave, we don't want them leaving.
We want them staying there and doing the work.
But on the toxicity side, we want to be keeping them out.
And so if we could better understand
the regulation between a residence
program and then the egress program and what makes it come on or go
off, I think then that we could manipulate that access a little bit further.
But it does add a lot of complexity to even interpreting the data that we're
getting out, right?
Maybe I'll ask a follow-up. So do you think there are truly resident cells that
actually never leave? Or do you think that all of our so-called resident cells have
this ability to pop in and out?
It's an interesting question. So based on what we've seen in mice
and the time frames that we've looked, we do think there are some cells that'll
just never, ever leave. They will eventually just either die in the
tissue or die with the host.
What dictates that? Its ability to actually leave or not, I'm not
sure.
But it does look like there are some cells that'll just
never have the
desire to leave.
Thank you.
So
for our last speaker, I'd like to call up Dr.
Gabriel Nunez, who is from Michigan
and has, in my opinion, one of the most exciting new
mouse models in
this space. I think has a lot of potential even beyond immune-related adverse
events, obviously. Thank you for coming.
Thank you for inviting me.
So I think we have mentioned today about
the dilemma we have that, of course, we need
to enhance the immunity against
tumors. But then when we play with
important physiological pathway, we
going to have side effects, and this has
been mentioned today.
Colitis is an important one. We heard today,
seem to be the more important cause of death, adverse effect.
As we mentioned also, the CTLA-4
therapy is what is probably causing most of the colitis,
but we typically use combination therapy.
That increases the
percentage of patients that develop colitis, and I think
could be lethal.
So as you probably know,
CTLA blockade, this is a pathway that is
important physiologically. When you delete this
gene in mice,
you basically have
very adverse effect with severe lymphoproliferative
disorders and so forth. So this is something that we need,
and we
blocking it to try to enhance the tumors.
But if you're going to block an important physiological pathway, you would
expect autoimmunity and other alterations
because this is what it's for. This pathway is not there to
block antitumor immunity. It's there to block adverse effect
of physiological effects.
So,
there are three different ways that you could anticipate
blockade of CTLA-4 being a
molecule on CD4 cells, interact and activate T
cells,
that binds to B7.
We want a B7 at the compete with the CD28, so that by doing that,
basically limit the
proliferation of naive T cells in response to TCR engagement
and also, of course, act on regulatory T cells, so
restrict the separation of regulatory T cells.
All this work was done primarily by Bernard Locke, which he was at the time,
was a postdoc from Vancouver, Canada.
So as you know,
we work with mice in the laboratory,
but what you probably not aware of, many of you, is that the mice that we work
with are very artificial in terms of the microbiota.
The veterinarians have put a lot of effort over the years to
get a very hygienic mice, and in the
'70s and '80s,
all the commercial suppliers of mice, derive the mice with
eight bacteria.
So the laboratory mice we have now, they come from eight bacteria that were put in
in the '70s and in the '80s. And then over time, they
acquire contaminants, and that's what we call it microbiota at the
moment. Clearly not very
physiological, very artificial, but that's what we have at the moment.
So we try, like many others, try to develop a model of CTLA
blockade with colitis, and we
have no effect using commercial suppliers.
So we reason that perhaps these mice have their own
microbiota. That's why we're not getting any effects.
So as you know, mice that carry free-living
microbiome display features of human immune disease.
So these are mice that were generated in two different ways.
Either you get germ-free mice and you gavaged
microbiota from widely caught mice.
In this case, the first mice came from farms close to NIH in
Maryland,
or you could do all the types of develop warlings
in which basically the entire microbiota, not just the gut microbiota, it
come from
a wild mouse.
So these
symbiotes, these
co-host coevolve with the host. And
different
model has been shown to model better human disease than the
traditional laboratory mice that we use.
So we started out with this sort of model in which we have a
SPF mice from Jackson or other sources.
We give them antibiotics to deplete the indigenous microbiota, and
we gavaged microbiota from wild-caught mice.
So these are microbiota from wild mice.
We start with the
CTLA-4 blockade. It's a GT2A antibody, an CTLA-4
antibody, and a PD-1 antibody. And later on, we
noted that the PD-1 antibody was not needed to develop
colitis.
So this is what we found. So like many M4 people working in the
lab, mice from Jackson, Taconic, Charles River, when you put
this protocol, they don't induce colitis whatsoever.
But if you gavaged now the wild microbiota, you have a very pronounced, this is the
lipocalin. It's like a protecting you see in patients with IBD.
You can see very high colitis.
And up a third. OopsI'm a pathologist.
So this is what it looks like.
This is normal mouse. So to confirm this, we use germ-free mice, and
we give them a wild microbiota or SPF mice, and with the control
antibody or the anti-Cil4 antibody.
So the only mice that develop colitis, it was the mice
were gavage with a wild microbiota.
You can see here, you don't have to be a pathologist to see the
thickness of this. It's infiltrated with many immune cells,
particularly T cells.
And this is when you
give the control antibody. So basically nothing happened.
You put SPF from Jackson, nothing happens.
This is the colitis here. Lipocalin close to 4,000,
5,000. And this is the histology. It's very easy to read, basically
30 versus 0.
So we asked the question, you need adapted
immunity to develop this colitis.
So we transferred the same experiments in germ-free, the RAG mice, so they
lack T and B cells.
So we found that the RAG mice were totally
protected, shown here.
So clearly this is driven by adapted immunity, presumably T
cells to develop colitis.
What kind of colitis did you get? So we analyzed the tissue.
This mostly was colitis, but also in some animals, we have ileal
enteritis also. But largely was
cecal and colitis, and also other parts of the
colon was also involved. What we saw was a
tremendous response of interferon-gamma
CD4 producing T cells, CD4 cells. So this is a
20-fold increase. This is
counting different flow cytometry experiments and counting this.
There was also increases in other populations of CD4 T cells, like
interferon-gamma 17 co-producers or
17 only. Also some other increase in the
interferon-gamma CD8 T cells, but they were
not as much as the CD4 Th1 type
T cells.
So,
what we also found that there was a depletion of
peripheral Tregs. So the thymic
Tregs were not depleted. So this is a flow-un gated CD4 cells.
This is the gated on FoxP3. And typically in the intestine, you have one
to one ratio. The percentage of
thymic-derived Tregs to
a RAG1/RAG2,
that's the way it's defined in the mouse, FoxP3 positive is one to
one. But when you deplete with the antibody,
deplete the peripheral Tregs, now the thymic Tregs
become now more abundant, three to fourfold greater than
the peripheral Tregs. So clearly we found a clear
depletion of the so-called peripheral Tregs out of
the total FoxP3. You define the total, you would not see much an effect.
So you really need to define your peripheral
Tregs in order to see
a depletion. And this could be very complicated in the humans because the
definitions are not very clear cut in the human
populations.
So what
is the cell responsible for this colitis?
So we do traditional experiments with depletion, with monoclonal
antibody deplete CD4 or CD8.
And there you can see here the control showing we treat relative CD4, we
deplete CD4. And when we use anti-CD8, we deplete CD8.
Clearly this was a CD4-dependent colitis shown here.
We basically abolish the colitis when we deplete
CD4 but not CD8. And this is the histology also showing with the
CD4, we abolish the colitis. This is also as
suspected Th1 type of response. We could
block by neutralizing interferon-gamma with an antibody.
We go from here, you can see the edema.
You see here the muscular layer, the epithelium, the surface, the lamina.
Here is the mucosa infiltrated with T cells.
That totally is look like this. Totally normal when you block
interferon-gamma. So this is interferon-gamma
CD4-depending colitis in this model.
We did single cell analysis, particularly to define the
clonality of these T cells. This
basically collaborated the data, traditional flow cytometry.
Here you can see in one and three, this is the two types of
populations of Th1, the PD-1 positive, PD-1 negative.
You can see here in blue, they expand while other cells like naive T
cells and follicular T cells, they
are depleted as well as some of the Tregs populations.
But this is where we're really looking at this data.
So, what we found in the normal mouse, most of
these Th1 populations, PD-1 positive or PD-1
negative, they only have one single receptor we identify in
the analysis of
5,000 CD4 positive T cells. But when you
treat it with a CD4 blocking antibody, and you look at this
now, and these are colitic mice, you see now
a little clonality. Some of these are represented about 100-fold.
So, 10%, some of the clones, they are between 5%
and 10%, all the CD4s are Th1.
So this is unprecedented. I never seen 5% or
10% all the T cells have the same receptor in
the column
after this
treatment.So is the
peripheral T-reg depletion required or not for colitis?
So we address this in two different ways.
One of them, we know previous work show that these
antibodies deplete through the Fc receptor, and then they use
NKT cells or macrophages to deplete the cells.
So we use first the FcR
gamma receptor
knockout, and also we generated, in collaboration with Takeda
Pharmaceuticals, a camelid antibody
that
was developed actually by our chair here today
in the meeting.
So
we use those two approaches here,
and this is the
knockout mice. Here you can see these mice, the
lipocalin here, they don't develop colitis. You can see here.
And this is the histology here.
And you can see here on the bottom, this is the FoxP3 gating.
You could see that you deplete from 43 to 10.9.
These are peripheral T-regs. These are Helios negative
R gamma T FoxP3 positive. But in the knockout now
restore now the number to 42. So
these mice,
Fc receptor gamma is required signaling for the
depletion through the CTLA-4 antibody.
And we also, it's not very clear because it's a PDF
my postdoc sent me yesterday, but we use also the
humanized CTLA-4 mouse. So this is basically using the
knockout CTLA-4, which replace with a gene from the human.
And now you can use ipilimumab here, the antibody.
And we found this totally reproduces the data.
So using the clinical
antibody would show that you need our
microbiota. The SPF mouse, they will not give you colitis like we saw in the mouse.
And also
for colitis, you need the Fc
receptor because we use ipilimumab that have,
in the Fc region, have three point mutations that abolish the Fc
effector function, and then you don't have colitis.
So in theory, this reagent could be very useful in the clinic.
I'll show you later on.
So what about the tumor effect? What did we learn about that?
So we use
three different models of tumors.
We use three groups of mice. CTLA-4 only,
and 9D9 is the
antibody that's similar to the clinical, but is the mouse antibody.
We also have an extender, because this
single molecule,
single domain antibody have very short half-lives.
So we need to increase the half-life with a live extender, the
H11. So we use an antibody, I think
you have a cartoon later on, and then we use the isotype control.
This is the antibody developed by our chair here.
This one, H11, in a paper in PNAS
2018, and this is the paper by Sato et al.
from Takeda that they basically make the link to
antiserum albumin to have increased the half-life of
antibody.
So the results were very clear. This is the first model, M38 tumor
cells.
Both
the CTLA-4 and the H1, sorry, that they have a
live extender block the tumor development equally.
But
only the CTLA-4 antibody induce colitis.
Lacking Fc, the
H11 with the HLE extender did not. So basically, we're
able to show requirement of Fc effector
for
colitis, but not for tumor anti-tumor development.
So you could basically use a strategy in which you
don't have the Fc portion, and you get anti-tumor effect, but no
colitis. And this is basically
another model. This is M38, but you can see here the pictures, both of them
basically block the tumors equally.
But this one gives you the colitis, but this one did not, shown here.
Yeah.
So this is another model, the C26 model. We have the same effect.
The CTLA-4 antibody, both of them, this is using PD-1 as
well. It's a combination to mimic more the clinical situation.
Both of them, combination block tumor development here and
here. Sorry, this is the lipocalin.
So this is
the only one that they do colitis is the CTLA-4.
And this is the tumor, both of them block
tumor development. This is the isotype control shown here.
So
far, this work was published in 2024.
Immune checkpoint blockade induce colitis is microbiota dependent.
An active adaptive immunity is required.
CTLA-4 blockade in microbiota from
wild mice result in inflammation.
And in this model, CD4 Th1 is required.
We just don't know in the human, but we saw
looking at literature that we saw an increase in CD4 Th1, but the other populations
also increased. So we don't know if this model totally
recapitulate the human's physiology or not.
That's something have to be tested.
And we saw increases in other populations, but we think these are mostly by
standard effects. There is a selective depletion of
peripheral T-regs, which are easily to discern in the mouse
because we have a better definition of the peripheral T-regs than in the
human.So this CD4 nanobodies or similar
strategies can be used to stimulate antitumor responses without
inducing colitis.
So we have now tried to understand which of these
receptors are recognized and increased.
I showed you some of that, 10%
of the CD4 bear a single receptor. So we clone the top
24 receptors, we put it into hybridoma cell
line, and we are screening now using a reporter and
fNAb-GFP.
We use 10% of these cells and cultural bacteria.
This is actually from a real experiment. You can see a hit here.
Now, this, when you put this culture, now
46% of this, they are activated, of the receptor
by a bacterial population. This is very similar to the CD3 control.
So these are very strong responses.
And this is some of the
data we have now. These are different
growing conditions, anaerobic conditions, aerobic
conditions. We found some of the clones, like here, like
three,
this one, six I think it is, 23. Many of them you can see
they can recognize
bacteria antigens. So right now we're cloning the antigens.
There are also some of them, like this one here, that actually seem to be
autoreactive, but we don't know much about that.
Seem to be autoreactive, but we don't know where the target is.
But it looks like the majority are reactive against
microbial antigens. Okay?
These receptors there. So they are this here, they're included during the colitis.
They're actually
acting, trying to respond to microbial antigens.
So this is where under homeostatic conditions, we have many symbiotes.
Typically, these are kept in check by a number of mechanisms, including the
peripheral T-regs, which blocks the induction of colitis in
response. We know some of these Th1, so a majority are reacting
to antigens in the symbiotes, in the microbiota.
When we block colitis, we basically deplete this population
in the animal model. So now this
Th1 different producing cell expand, and
I told you these clonotypes, they
recognize largely microbial antigens that we think
do the damage. So they are now oligoclonal response.
So these work suggests a strategy to
increase the tumor immunity without having colitis
through altering the FC portion of the
antibodies.
But I think these have to be tested in the humans to make sure that these...
Whether in the humans, the
Th1 different gamma is the major culprit, that's something had to be tested
also in clinical trials. In the mouse it's very clear, but the bacteria
may be different from human to mice, and that's something have to be
discerned, investigated. Thank you very much.
I think I have one more picture. I already mentioned the work
from Bernard Lord, mostly of the work and the collaboration
with Takeda Pharmaceuticals, and also some people from
University of Michigan, like Weiping Xu and members of the lab, and then
Osaka University, which I'm also a family member there,
the laboratory of Sho Yamazaki. I like to recognize
Eiji Ichikawa, which did a tremendous work in the
last part of my data I show you.
Thank you very much.
Hi, great talk. Have you been able to do fecal microbiota
transplants from patients who developed colitis into your germ-free mice?
And do you see that those mice are predisposed to colitis?
Will you repeat it? The-
Oh. Have you been able to get patient samples from patients who develop checkpoint
colitis and then put those into germ-free mice? And do you see they get colitis?
No, we
were trying to do that when we were trying to answer the comments from the
reviewers, but that was
not easy to do that. We didn't have... So we thought about that.
That's a very good experiment, and we wanted to do it.
It just became more and more complicated.
I work in the pathology department, so
sometimes it's
difficult. You have to work with oncologists and so.
But maybe I can talk to my chair here to do those
experiments. I totally agree, that's a very good experiment.
I'm not sure what the results will be. Yeah.
Happy to collaborate on that.
Yeah, great talk. So, my question is, so you
have a ratio of peripheral T-regs versus N T-regs.
So did you look at what is happening to the N T-regs maybe in terms of their
number and their phenotype after depletion of the P T-regs?
Well, I
losing my ear. I lost my ear.
Sorry. I'll speak louder. Sorry. My bad.
So,
in your presentation, you show that the antibody
is able to deplete the P T-regs.
Yes.
And I'm asking if you kind of looked into the N T-regs,
after the depletion of the P T-regs, to see if anything happened to them in terms
of their phenotype or maybe whether they expanded.
Just trying to see whether the N T-regs is more
representative of what we are seeing in the human population.
No, we haven't done that experiment.
The only thing we did, and I haven't mentioned to you, is that we look at the
depletion, this is another very important topic, in the tumor itself-
Mm-hmm
... when we're doing this experiment.
So in the same mice that we treated, we took samples from the tumor,
because we are the only ones at that time that were able to do this because there
was no model.
Right.
So this is a model that allows you to look at the tumorsand allow
you to look at that. So there's a difference.
Mm-hmm.
We could see a depletion of
the FoxP3
with the antibody in the tumor,
in our model, which may be different from Jackson mice.
Yeah.
But the Defc minus, we have minimal, so it's still
anti-tumor, but we didn't see much inhibition, suggesting that perhaps that's not
the main driver of
the cause of anti-tumor effects-
I see
... depleting the FoxP3. But again, this is
an animal model, and it's a
complicated situation. But your experiment that you asked me, we didn't do that
experiment.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Such great work, Gabi. I have a question about the wild
microbiome. Is it
more pro-inflammatory, and does it break down the barrier
and lead to stimulation of the immune response against these
bacterial antigens?
Yeah. The bacterial populations are different.
As I mentioned, we work with laboratory mice, who's nothing to do with a mouse.
These mice were basically rederived in the '70s
with eight bacteria.
This is what we have right now.
Immunologists don't know this.
They were literally derived by Jackson because they
thought that it would allow commercially to be an advantage to them so they
can grow more, and also they thought it would be more,
for everybody would have the same eight bacteria.
Well, that turned out to be wrong because virtually after
this, when you send it to facilities around the country, like
universities, they start acquiring other bacteria.
So they're all over the place. And then Jackson have their own.
So
we're using mice, which is nothing to do with physiology, basically.
And so, yes, these people, they are very
high-impact papers in cell and science, showing you that in some models,
you get a model with these mice, but not with Jackson mice.
But I'm not saying that all the data we have to throw out away. No.
I say that some data we have to throw it away, but not all.
Some systems are more depending on the microbiota, or they have no
dependency whatsoever. Those are probably okay.
But there's some models in which the microbiota,
physiological microbiota, is probably essential, like the model I show you.
So
it depends. So this is
concerning, put it this way. I've worked all my life with Jackson mice.
But looking at some experiments and conclusions may be
wrong because we-
No, I agree
... so that is a problem.
Just one last question.
Easy to fix.
Have you looked at the wild microbiome subsets at all?
I noticed there's helico bacteria in there, right?
Are they particularly pro-inflammatory, or are any of the
other subsets more pro-inflammatory?
Yeah. There are many bacteria that we cannot culture, put it this way.
They also have many enterobactericia, like E.
coli, for example, Jackson has no E.
coli, no Klebsiella, no enterobactericia. It's totally artificial.
We have enterobactericia. Jackson mice have zero.
They don't have an E. coli, no Klebsiella, no Proteus mirabilis, nothing.
So I mean, this is not natural.
Jackson. Taconi has some.
So your model depends on the enterobactericia.
Don't work with Jackson because they don't have any. Zero.
Can I ask a question?
Yeah. We're actually at the discussion time, so we can open this up to
questions from anyone about any part of this.
So I think that'd be great if you want to start, Dr. Pauken.
So I love your mouse model and the ability to use
the more wild microbiome in terms of increasing the
sensitivity to checkpoint inhibitor-induced colitis.
So the question that I have
is how much of it do you think is acting locally within the
gut, versus do you think that you're kicking up a systemic
response when you give checkpoint inhibitors, and so you have kind of this
involvement of both the local and peripheral immune response?
So we tried to answer that question by using inhibitors that block
the mobilization that you were talking.
Mm.
We got a very strange result. We got more inflammation.
Oh, okay.
I think the reason is because we probably block the T regs.
Mm-hmm.
The peripheral T regs to move there.
So this is a complicated effect because you could block
the effectors that do the damage, but also you could block the peripheral T
regs.
So we were doing these experiments with the one that is a drug which
blocks many things, and we saw more inflammation.
It
was not blocking. We were surprised.
One interpretation is we're blocking also,
it could be they are resident, and we're blocking the peripheral T regs.
Mm.
So basically now we have more inflammation.
So it's complicated.
So we didn't see. We tried to do experiments you were doing.
Yeah.
We use the antibody that block,
and also we used a drug, a drug
that's widely used in the field to block
trafficking of lymphoid cells to the intestine.
And we got actually
slightly more inflammation, put it this way.
Mm.
That's a really interesting point, and I think one that
I don't necessarily think enough about is that when you have a
mobilization from the periphery, it's not necessarily
exclusively your pro-inflammatory cells-
Mm-hmm
... but also your regulators.
Mm-hmm.
And certainly in the 2024 paper, where
Jason Schinkel's lab originally described the use of the IV antibody
method to timestamp,
he saw that regulatory T cells
actually had a much higher entry rate into a
lung cancer model than CD8 T cells.
And so if you pan blocked migration, that would impact both.
The tumors actually did better because the T regs weren't coming
in.And because the CD8 T cell migration in was so low
anyway, the cells that were in the lung could actually do a lot of the
heavy lifting. And so I do think that with migration, it
absolutely could be a double-edged sword.
And
it's interesting to do the experiment, actually see what happens.
Like they get more inflammation, they get less inflammation.
Yeah. So we get more inflammation, but you block migration with a drug.
By nobody selective, you're probably blocking many populations migrating.
Yeah.
And we think,
and we're totally surprised. We thought they're going to be a block, right?
Yeah.
No, more inflammation. So we think the most likely explanation is that
we're blocking regulatory cells, that they are to stop
these. When you have trillions of microbes,
there's a lot of emphasis in evolution
to-- Because some of those, they go through to minimize the inflammation.
Otherwise, everybody would be inflamed here in this room, and we are not.
So clearly, there are very strong ways to prevent the entry of those symbiotes
in the lamina propria. But if they enter, because they do, to
prevent the activation of T cells.
These have been there very strongly put in evolution because
this is from all the animals. They have these.
So this is very important. Otherwise, you die.
So
I think
we don't know exactly what causes this more inflammation, but one
possibility is we're blocking the pre-floated regs to get
into the tissue.
Yeah.
So we have to use a different approach.
That honestly is what my guess would be in humans as well.
From the data that we have, the
biggest expanded population of Tregs that we see are the
S1P1R positive Tregs. And there are
a lot of resident memory cells that are active in the colon.
And so I bet you would block the Tregs that are coming in,
and you'd have plenty of effector cells causing a problem.
Yeah. So we have to be cautious if we develop strategies to do this by the direct,
because we may be blocking also the entry of
the regulatory cells. We make things worse, like we found in our mouse.
So we have to be cautious. I think there are ways to get around this.
I would love to have this Fc-.
So we're going to ask you,
what about that antibody? Can we use in the clinic?
Well, so
what's happened clinically, and there's a question about this
online, too.
Pharmaceutical companies have actually moved in the other direction towards
antibodies that have enhanced Fc function.
Part of the reason for that is the initial data from
B16 melanoma,
and this isn't with the Jackson microbiota, but that
data showed that we needed the Fc receptor function for
optimal response. Mice respond much better to CTLA-4
than humans. So the thought was, well, maybe what we're looking at in humans is
the suboptimal response. If we enhanced it, we would get a better
response. And those drugs, they're being clinically
explored. They do seem to have,
I'll say,
it's really seemed, the data's not
published in a rigorous way, but they seem to have more clinical activity, at least
in some kinds of cancer. They also have more toxicities.
We have looked at it. Because they're not
published
antibodies, these patients are on trials.
I can't show any of the data from that, but they are
used. There is one antibody,
tremelimumab, that has reduced Fc
gamma receptor function, and there's questions
about how active it is compared to ipilimumab.
It is hard to tease that out because they haven't been directly compared,
but that's led multiple companies to go towards the Fc enhancement.
I bet that it's dependent on the specific system, though.
I think your data's very clear. In some
models,
if you just block CTLA-4, you get really good anti-tumor
responses. And I'm sure that is the case in humans for
some kinds of cancer, and maybe not all of them.
But if we can figure out which ones are which, it could
allow us to separate toxicity, at least in some settings, from
response.
Also say that there are experiments ongoing blocking
the S1P1R receptor in humans. So we
will see if that makes things worse.
I was going to ask you about the
S1PR1 receptor, because isn't it normally involved in
egress?
From the lymph node. And so we think they're coming out
of the lymph node and then getting back into the-
And they just haven't down-regulated it yet.
Yeah. We think they're new. If we could do that in people,
which would be very hard. But
my hypothesis would be
that they are new immigrants into the
colon.
Very interesting.
But obviously, it's very hard to know that.
And we're looking very early on in the response.
Part of what we've been trying to do is
avoid looking at downstream consequences
of mucosal disruption. Because I think that then you get to final
common pathways of innate inflammatory responses, and
it's no longer telling you what's starting this.
If you strip the mucosa off, all forms of colitis start to look the same.
Yeah. I do think that the
sampling as early as possible to get at the drivers instead of the
consequences is really critical, and certainly can be challenging for
adverse events because they have to identify that there's a problem and
then get in, and then you have to mobilize the tissue collection team.
But it's really important, I think, to be able to study what's happening.
I think it's also important that the people taking biopsies
understand what the purpose of it is.
So, for our experiments, we really target
adjacent normal appearing tissue rather than sort of
the most diseased looking tissue.
And that's, again, because we're trying to look at the early responses
rather than... what happens when the
mucosa actually starts to fall apart.
Yeah.
Questions from the audience. There are a few more of them online.
One of the questions that's in here is about,
when are Tregs depleted? When are they expanded?
And
the question is, "I'm confused." And I think
that's the
situation in the field right now, and we still don't have a clear answer.
And I think that's why it's so important to
have animal models where we can ask lots
of different kinds of questions and really be able to say, "These
are the situations when depletion happens.
This is what occurs when there's depletion." So that we can then
compare that to what we see in patients and
form hypotheses, either that we can test in trials or at least as ways of
understanding the human data. Without a mouse model, it becomes
much, much harder to test hypotheses.
And so, that's what I think is so exciting about
this model here, is that it allows us to start to address those questions.
We do not have a clear answer about what's happening in people.
I think in some
settings, it's clear that we get expansion
of Treg populations. Are they functional?
What are those functions? It's still an open question.
Well, and I do think if you do have an animal model, if you're using a
CTLA-4 inhibitor, it's really important to look.
Yeah.
To actually look and measure, is your clone of
CTLA-4 deleting your Tregs in your tissues of
interest? Because
there are reports from the literature of like, clone X is depleting, clone Y is
depleting, and then there's other reports that like, no, they don't.
And I do think there's a lot of tissue dependence in terms of whether or not you'll
actually get deletion. And so checking is really
important. Don't just assume that you will because somebody else published that you
will, or assume that you won't because somebody else published that you won't.
Yeah, but the problem is the definition of peripheral Tregs.
If you look in our testing, you look at FoxP3, there's no depletion because you
don't see them,
because that's so broad, the definition.
And in many human studies, they only look FoxP3 CD4 positive.
That's the only thing they look at. By doing that, basically you can't even look.
So what is very interesting, when we look at that data that you were
analyzing, we saw a depletion of peripheral
Tregs according to our definition of peripheral Tregs.
But we were not 100% sure those are
real peripheral. But we could find
a gene signature that appears to be peripheral
Tregs and were depleted in the human samples with a CTLA-4
antibody. But we were not totally happy with it because there was no
clear-cut definition. This is our definition that
we-- We basically
made up the definition, but if that is a correct definition, I
cannot tell you. But we saw the depletion.
Right.
But maybe they truly are the ones.
I just don't know for sure.
So, we
took your definition, reanalyzed our data, and we saw exactly the
same thing.
That's why we added all of the extra samples to start to see, okay, well, what
happens when we go from 24 patients to a few dozen?
And I think that does help with humans.
You add more and more data, you start to see new things.
And we're still in the analysis phase of this, so this is-- I mean, it's
early data and we hope to have more to say in the next few months.
I think that we are out of time, but thank you all for your
attention. And again, I want to thank both of the other speakers
for agreeing to come today. Your talks were fantastic, and I really appreciate it.
Thank you, everyone.
So you're saying that actually what they are doing is actually enhancing those C
agonist effect?
Yeah, that's what they're-
This is in the tumor, but I think they're going to
have more colitis.
Oh, they do. They definitely do. There's certain-- I can't
specifically reply to it, but I consult for every one of those companies
because they're seeing astronomical rates of colitis.
Yeah.
But the interesting thing-
I have a different approach.
But the thing that's-
They didn't consult me.
But the part that's interesting is that what they're going after
are GI tumors, and they're seeing much better GI responses.
So there's also
a benefit to that. So they're doing microsatellite stable
colon cancer. They're doing pancreas cancer, and there, the
responses are much better. They don't see any responses in those diseases to
a classic checkpoint blockade. But they do see responses with their antibiotics.
And so we'll see if that plays out in the other phase